if you watch cnn or msnbc which i do not
recommend but if you do
you will soon discover that
conservatives and leftists republicans
and democrats
are living in what increasingly seems
like
completely different universes
completely different framings
understandings
of the world now this would especially
be true you would think for the party
and the group of people who believe that
babies are not babies that men or women
that up is down the left is right but
the left seems to believe that it is we
republicans
we conservatives we right-wingers who
are
the lunatics nicole wallace decided to
talk about the fact-free
right-wing with of all people al
sharpton
i was off a couple days last week and i
tuned in to a little bit of fox news in
prime time and was aghast
i mean they are pumping flagrant lies
into the millions of viewers on their
network they are saying they are
interviewing
these lunatics these they call them
lawyers i'm not sure how many of them
have law degrees
who are saying that there are million
votes here and observers not here
these cases have been filed they have
gone before judges who were democratic
and republican appointees and they've
all been thrown out
i mean do you share president obama's
concern about this
alternate universe of fact-free
information that's being
pumped into trump's base i
shared absolutely and then some we
can have in any political climate
different opinions but we can't have
different facts
we are now in a nation where facts don't
matter you make
up facts and not only do you have an
alternative
uh reality how do you debate someone
that is dealing from a totally
fictitious
premise how do you debate someone who
is coming from a totally fictitious
premise says al
sharpton one of the most famous liars in
american politics
on msnbc which has lied and gotten
everything wrong
for the past four years we will examine
how we got to the alternative universes
and how to come back home i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from
jane de belleville what a lovely name
that is from jane who says
censorship on social media for the left
is the equivalent of
book burning on a massive massive scale
this is true and actually the left is
engaging in book burning right now
explicitly
talking about how great it would be to
burn books one book in particular
which we touched on a little bit
yesterday a book that argues against
transiting
the kids turning little boys into
looking more like little girls
but i actually think the right gets the
idea of book burning and censorship
a little bit wrong i think they're
they're kind of misstating their
argument and as the as a result of that
we're giving the left
more of an opportunity to attack us we
will get all into that it actually all
has to do
with how we frame the world uh you know
this is a time of increasing strife of
increasing danger of it seems increasing
insecurity which is why it's very good
to defend yourself
the ability to defend yourself and your
family has never been more important or
critical and you need to be prepared
that is why personal defense network has
the world's
largest collection of high-quality
educational self-defense material on the
internet
from firearms to self-defense to home
defense training
personal defense network will come to
your rescue quite literally
this is not just some like old training
video out of the 80s where you put it on
you know and you just sort of watch it
doesn't no
these guys have spent many months
developing content specifically
for these trying times and they don't
just tell you what to do they explain
the whys and the hows
to help you develop your skills on your
own i was so thrilled when personal
defense network came
on the show because look i just moved to
tennessee this is a place where you
actually are allowed to defend yourself
me i'm not i don't exactly have you know
special forces training here
uh but it's a wonderful way to get to
learn how to defend yourself so right
now text code
mich ael to 47 47 47
the discount that you will get will
automatically apply a checkout
because you're a listener of mine their
premium membership will be i kid you not
three dollars
three dollars for the first year pdn
tells me this is one of their best deals
ever because this plan normally sells
for 69 bucks text code michael mich ael
to 47 47 47 and the discount will
automatically apply
at checkout alternative universes you
know nicole wallace
doesn't have any credibility when she
mentions this on msnbc msnbc has been
running conspiracy theory after
conspiracy theory for the past four
years starting with the russia hoax
denying the the spying activities
of the obama administration on the trump
campaign then going to the tax returns
you remember they said trump has evaded
taxes
we have them here and then rachel maddow
opens them on the air and it turns out
he actually paid his taxes
so they don't have any credibility but
she could have gotten away with it had
she not then turned
to al sharpton al sharpton who launched
his career
on a lie people forget this now but al
sharpton
really burst to national prominence with
the tawanna brawley hoax
that was a rape hoax in what was it the
90s
where this gal accused these men of
raping her
it became very racially charged and it
was just complete
bs and al sharpton has lied about so
many other things he has no regard for
the truth
whatsoever he is a cynic i mean he's a
true cynic
where i don't even know that he's a liar
so much as he just doesn't
doesn't care at all whether something is
true or false but the point that they're
getting at
sort of hilariously depicts this
this different framing that we have the
left is looking at the country
through a completely different angle
than the right is
right now and the right is more correct
than the left is
but we need to understand how the
framing works i think sometimes
we get a little too comfortable on the
right just talking about
facts you know just talking about the
raw
raw material as though we don't have
interpretive lenses ourselves i'll give
you an example of this i'll give you an
example completely
out of the partisan sphere so completely
out of you know
biden or trump or politics harry styles
just put on a dress harry styles word
dress i don't even really know who harry
styles is i kind of recognize the name
what is he a singer or an actor or
something like that he's some show
business guy
and he takes this picture wearing a very
silly dress
but as far as i can tell he's not
wearing the dress ironically he's
wearing the dress
earnestly and candace owens
my friend and now colleague candace
owens tweets out
there is no society that can survive
without strong men the east knows this
and the west
the steady feminization of our men at
the same time that marxism is being
taught to our children
is not a coincidence it's an outright
right attack bring back manly men and
she trends for this on twitter
people were so upset that she said this
how dare you suggest
that harry styles can't wear a dress
now some people on the right the more
libertarian right get this wrong they
say who cares if he wears a dress it has
nothing to do with me
that's nothing to do with culture you
know it doesn't have to do with politics
first of all yes it does
yes it does we need to stop this silly
thing that everybody can do whatever
they want to do and that has no
political or cultural effect at all
first of all it obviously has a cultural
effect
if men start wearing dresses that is a
description of culture
what is culture it involves our
cultivation it involves how we behave
in the world right now men wear suits
a little bit at least they wear suits
that's just a cultural norm
men i guess could wear dresses but that
would be a different culture
but moreover it is political politics
is just how we all get along together
that i know we have a very narrow
definition of politics now to
just what certain departments of the
government do but that's not
historically what politics is
and i think conservatives are very silly
to adopt this narrow view of politics
politics is just how we all get along
together so obviously culture affects
politics
politics affects culture it's a little
bit of a blurry line
and it is political when a public figure
does something
in public that is a political statement
and the political statement here is
that men ought to wear dresses and it's
something the right doesn't get either
because
sometimes the ride either gets too
permissive or too moralizing about this
and the real answer is somewhere in the
middle
i can't believe i even have to say this
it's so so
weird that our culture is decayed so
much that i have to say this obvious
truth
men wearing dresses dressing in drag is
funny
because men are not supposed to wear
dresses
it is funny i know some people want to
really moralize and say drag isn't funny
it's
merely an abomination it's merely that
okay but it is kind of funny it's funny
because it's incongruous
because men are not supposed to wear
dresses but you need that second part
for it to be funny too
if you live in a world where you think
men are supposed to wear dresses then
it's not funny
right this is something the left managed
to do they somehow managed to make drag
queens boring i don't know how you do
that
they somehow managed to make these crazy
insane parades there's a parade in in
new york on coney island i think it's
called the mermaid parade and it's where
all these drag queens dress up in crazy
costumes and it's very weird you know
that's whole point of it is supposed to
be weird
now we're supposed to be told this is
entirely normal but it's not normal
men are not in dresses the fact that
a man can put on all of the various
accoutrements and adornments of
womanhood of femininity
and still be obviously a man is what
makes it funny because it means that
there is such a thing as masculinity
there is such a thing as manliness
you can dress it all up like a woman but
still
you're a man well we've lost sight of
that now because we believe that men can
be women and women can be men and
genders a social construct
and sex isn't real even though it's
innate and our sexual dispositions are
so innate we can't change
we're born this way obviously there's so
many contradictions here
there's no such thing as gender but
women are the future the future is
female he said wait a second what
i thought there's no such thing as
female or male there's no such thing as
men and women but how the future is
female
and this actually gets to candace owens
point what candace is saying is
the left is attacking masculinity and
they say no we're not how dare you of
course the left is attacking
masculinity the left talks about toxic
masculinity all the time and they're not
talking about just
brutish machismo they're talking about
all masculinity as being toxic
the left says the future is female how
many times have you seen that t-shirt if
you go into a city
if you're on a college campus be a
feminist we all need to be feminists
not peopleists not humanists not human
whatever not not anything that is
all-encompassing of all people feminists
right because female is better than male
women are better than men
according to this new pyramid of
victimhood that the left is put forward
so you can't at the same time say the
future is female
men are toxic we need to get rid of
masculinity and also say
we're not attacking masculinity of
course you are that's the point candace
is making
and the thing is everything she said is
true society cannot exist without strong
men
you need strong men usually with guns
to protect your society from threats
from disorder from violence
violence from outside invading armies
war
and violence within from criminals
that's why you need cops that's why you
need the military and if a society
doesn't have those two things
they're not going to have any society at
all they're not going to have any
civilization at all because you need law
enforcement
if you want the law to have any effect
and if you don't have
law in a society you don't have a
civilized nation
of course you need these things
there's nothing misogynist there's
nothing sexually chauvinistic
about saying that men should act like
men there's nothing
homophobic transphobic phobic phobic
whatever
there are two words here that you can
use to refer to someone who is acting
like a woman
womanly and womanish
two words they mean the same thing don't
they no they mean opposite things
when women act like women the word we
use is womanly
when men act like women the word we use
is womanish
it is good for women to be womanly it is
bad for men to be womanish
why is that because people are supposed
to do
the things that they are supposed to do
and we on the right have lost a sense of
this
we've lost a sense of what freedom
really means we've we've done exactly
what the founding fathers told us not to
do
the founding fathers said do not confuse
liberty and libertinism
do not confuse liberty which in the
traditional definition is not the
freedom
to do what you want to do but rather the
right to do what you ought to do
oriented toward virtue that's the
traditional understanding of liberty
it's kind of
it's morphed over time but even the
founding fathers who were living during
the height of say classical liberalism
understood that virtue is essential
you're doing what you ought to do not
being a liberty
totally important now our understanding
of liberty is yeah just do whatever you
want
if it feels good do it there's nothing
you're supposed to do at all because you
think
that i'm supposed to do one thing but
someone else might think i'm supposed to
do another so therefore there's no right
answer but there is a right answer there
is and this
this difference of framework is leading
to so much
of our confusion even on the issue of
free speech which we'll get to in a
second even on the issue of censorship
and book burning and all of that we are
supposed to do certain things
should a man hold a door for a woman yes
why
because it's polite because men are
physically stronger it's the right thing
to do
should a man pick up the tab yeah i
think so i think so i think that's a
good norm i think that's a good
more but we're inverting that we're
getting rid of that sort of thing
i looked at the senate the other day
this was just yesterday they were having
a debate over
i was it wasn't even a debate over masks
but it became a debate over masks and i
realized that the womanish
sherrod brown is exactly the kind of man
that's exactly the kind of problem that
candace owens was talking about
because on the floor of the u.s senate
what is supposed to be the greatest
deliberative body in the world
it broke out into bickering over who was
going to wear
a filthy cloth cloth mask over their
face
senator from ohio i'd start by asking
the presiding officer to please wear a
mask
as he speaks and people below him or i
can't tell you what to do but
i know that the behavior i don't wear a
mask when i'm speaking like
most senators well i'm most sensitive
i don't need your instruction from i
know you don't need my instruction but i
there clearly isn't much interest in
this body in public health
we have a president who hasn't shown up
at the coronavirus task force
meeting in months we have a majority
leader that calls us back here
to vote on an unqualified nominee and
and at the same time to vote for judge
after judge after judge
exposing all the people who can't say
anything i understand
the people in front of you and the
presiding officer and expose all the
staff here
and the majority leader just doesn't
seem to care
that is so embarrassing for sherrod
brown
sherrod brown should be very ashamed of
himself his family should be very
ashamed
to share a last name with that
individual
he shows up to the floor of the united
states senate where you were supposed to
make
persuasive speeches grand oratory
on the important public matters of the
day and what does he choose to do he
chooses to whine
and nag and passive aggressively
needle the presiding senator here that
would be a republican dan sullivan
for not wearing a cloth mask when he's
many many many many many feet away from
anybody even let's just
say for a minute that the masks are like
super duper effective let's just
let's go with that hypothetical dan
sullivan not wearing a mask when he's so
far away from everybody
ain't going to do anything it doesn't
matter at all
but sheridan um i want to well you
need to wear a mask i can't tell what
everyone else what to do but i'm telling
you what to do but actually he can't
sherrod brown has no right to tell dan
sullivan what to do especially as he's
presiding over this this hearing and
and dan sullivan responds in a manly way
he goes you don't you don't get to
lecture me about anything
no i'm going to sit here without my mask
because i'm speaking like an adult so
no sorry and you're and you're making us
vote right that's your job
you're a senator your job is to vote and
you're making this one unqualified
candidates okay if you think the
candidate's unqualified
make a speech about that don't just nag
and needle and whine it's pathetic
i feel like i'm don corleone talking to
johnny fontaine i want to shake sherrod
branson you're going can act like a man
what's the matter with you what's the
matter with this guy what's the matter
with our culture
that is not how men are supposed to
behave it's not how women are supposed
to behave
and it's certainly men should not be
doing a very
caricatured ridiculous impression of
such a womanish
ish sort of behavior it's absolutely
pathetic we we are not seeing
clearly the the framework
under which we should recognize our
society but if you do want to see
clearly who's at your door you should
use a ring
ring is so helpful you know there's a
thousand reasons
why protecting your home should matter
to you
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it
so you know ring has been with us since
basically the beginning of the show
you can see hear and speak to whoever is
at your door from anywhere with video
doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with easy to install
indoor and outdoor cameras protect your
whole home with ring alarm a powerful
affordable whole home security system
that you can easily install yourself i'm
very excited
i am very soon going to have a home in
nashville tennessee
just gotten here i can't wait to have it
and i'm
so pleased that i will have a ring
because look you want to know who's at
your door maybe in the middle of the
night
you want to know even who's dropping a
package off you want to know maybe if
your mother-in-law is going to come
visit you
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s comes with rings video
doorbell 3 and chime pro
the perfect way to start your ring
experience go to ring.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s that is ring.com slash
knowles can it w-l-e-s
so so pathetic also they have more
pressing matters even
again let's say that the
masks are super duper effective fine
let's say that
let's say that sherrod brown actually is
somewhat at risk
he has gone to the senate ostensibly
to work on public policy to make life
better
for the people to actually sacrifice a
little bit from his personal life
so that he can give to the public so he
can serve the public
and all he does is get up there and
whine about his personal safety
which is not at risk from dan sullivan
all that far away not wearing a cloth
mask
during a virus that has an
extraordinarily high survival rate
but even if it again even if it were
dangerous to him this prioritization of
of one's personal comfort and safety
over the public in the u.s
senate for goodness sakes very very
unmanly very much uh
proves candace owens's point
and the senate is really at risk here by
the way do you want more of sherrod
brown in the senate or less right now
the senate is run by republicans
it could be run by democrats it
seriously could it looked on election
night
you know when all the all the legally
counted votes
were coming in when the poll watchers
were there looked very clear
that republicans were going to hold the
senate and then you know
middle of the night people start
counting i mean david shaffer who's the
head of the georgia gop said that they
they closed down
vote counting at 10 30 at night
and then poll watchers went home and
then they illegally kept counting the
votes
until the wee hours of the morning well
when those votes came in
all of a sudden all the races tightened
up the senate is up for grabs and it's
going to come down to georgia
two senate races in georgia david perdue
and kelly loffler
two republicans they're running against
really bad hombres
well jon ossoff john ossoff is that
democrat who lost
a congressional seat and hollywood
poured a ton of money into him they made
him a big deal he was like beto
1.0 and then he lost and then what do
you do and as a democrat you fail up so
then he runs through senate he loses
again
but then they find some votes and so now
there's going to be a runoff
jon ossoff is just kind of a joke and
hopefully he loses
but there's another guy running who's
who's like a really bad guy
his name is rafael warnock he's running
against kelly laufler
kelly laufler was weakened a little bit
in her senate race because there were
some accusations of
some financial problems or whatever it
was all kind of murky but anyway
it weakened her a little bit in the race
raphael warnock
is a pastor i take it of some
denomination
and he's a real radical this guy
said just a few years ago in 2016 that
america needs to repent for its worship
of whiteness no matter what happens next
month more than a third of the nation
that would go along with this
is reason to be afraid america needs to
repent
for its worship of whiteness
on full display
this season how is it
that you can insult everybody
call muslims
something other than children of god
call mexicans
murderers and rapists insult the
disabled
how is that you can insult everybody but
then one weekend somebody discovers in
the recording that you
insult those whose
daughters and wives look like those who
have been supporting you
and then all of a sudden we can't take
it anymore i gotta repent for the
worship of whiteness
the worship of whiteness so what he's
talking about there is donald trump he
says trump
is you know he's a white basically he's
implying he's a white supremacist or
white identitarian of some sort
and he's insulting all people of other
races which is obviously not true
because donald trump outperformed mitt
romney
in 2016 among black and latino voters
but but moreover
he increased his support among black and
latino voters
substantially in 2020
from all the numbers that we have out
from the 2020 election i know it's still
being counted
all the numbers we have out he gained in
support among black
voters among latino voters among every
among black women among whatever all
every single group you want to look at
other than white men the one group he
lost support in
was white men everyone else he went up
so totally knocked down his promise also
the idea that america worships whiteness
is preposterous the only thing we ever
talk about in this country is how racist
and terrible america is
we only have one racially discriminatory
system of laws in this country
it's called affirmative action it
disadvantages white and asian applicant
i don't know why the asians got lumped
in but it disadvantages white and asian
applicants
to college and and employment and it
gives an advantage to black and hispanic
and other applicants
it's not the worship of whiteness
all we ever talk about white supremacy
the worst most terrible problem
if you look pew research did an analysis
of racial
consciousness in the country every
racial group has higher than 50
racial consciousness except for white
people they're the only people that
don't
and their racial consciousness is down
at about 15 people who say that their
their race is extraordinarily important
to their sense of identity
either important or very important and
of course ask any white person ask me i
guess i qualify you know little swarthy
but i think i qualify as a white guy
i don't when someone says are you what
is who are you what are you
do i say i'm i'm a white guy no that's
not it's not even like in the top 50.
i'm catholic i'm a new yorker i guess
originally no longer a new yorker now
i'm a good old southern boy in tennessee
i'm uh american i'm a conservative
i'm whatever i can go down the list
white guys
pretty low on the list but that would be
that would not be true on average for
people
of other races so the idea that we
worship what's crazy
but what it is is a way in to to attack
america's
founding to attack the idea of america
saying it's rotten to the core
those are alternate universes that we're
living in the one that says america is a
good place
it's the most racially tolerant place
ever in the history of the world
basically
and the one that says america's worships
whiteness
now warnock this lunatic this true
lunatic is wrong
we are right we the people who say now
race is not the most important thing in
this country
it's actually a good country it's good
for people of all races
and just calm down and shut up you know
we are correct that framing is right
there can be more and less correct
framings of how we view the world but
that warnock framing the one that says
america is hopelessly bigoted
that one could win that could win in
georgia and by the way if they win in
georgia if those two two races go
all of a sudden democrat and and if joe
biden becomes the president
all of a sudden democrats have control
of the senate that's not a great idea
that's not a good thing at all this guy
also the way you know he's also a
complete lunatic is he once
drove over his wife's foot he ran over
his wife's foot while they were having
an argument
if you try to run over your wife during
an argument you are a lunatic
but this guy's also mainstream in 2013
he delivered the benediction at the
public prayer service
at the second inauguration of barack
obama in march 2019
warnock hosted an interfaith meeting
on climate change at his church i feel
like i want to put quotes around
almost every word in that sentence uh al
gore showed up to that
so this guy is fairly mainstream and
this could throw the senate and it's an
election in georgia where there are lots
of irregularities
do you know in georgia they just
discovered
2600 votes
in a pro-trump county they i don't know
they just discovered it
good thing they started looking for him
again good thing conservatives made them
start looking for them again
because those 2 600 votes from the
pro-trump county guess they just
disappeared
meanwhile big tech and the main
mainstream i guess you would say
establishment media
are trying to call this election already
they're trying to describe themselves
as official sources and joe biden admits
who's really going to run the country
if he ascends to the presidency which we
will get to but
first if conservatives care about a free
press
they must abandon the establishment
media cartel
and support alternatives you should
replace
your cable and your new subscriptions
with the daily wire
you know in days past we used to say
well look at least there's that one
channel that's been on cable for a while
and they've been okay to us
i think this election threw that one out
the window i think
now conservatives look and they say wow
all these establishment networks
even the ones we thought we had they're
not doing it
they're not really with us come on over
to the daily wire we have big plans for
the next four years we've got candace
she's going to keep trending and keep
getting in trouble and we're going to
keep having her do it
because someone's got to speak the truth
in this crazy culture we've got prageru
behind our paywall now we've got prageru
on our streaming service which is great
because actually candace has a show on
prageru and so do i have the book club
on prageru
that's going to be over at daily wire
we've got news shows coming up we've got
a lot of fun new content we're going to
be making culture this year
replace your subscription to those
legacy establishment outlets
show your support for the daily wire
keep the leftist tears on coming
we'll be right back with a lot more
floyd county pro-trump county
just discovers 2600 ballots that had not
been counted
this will give president trump at least
an 800-vote
chomp into joe biden's current lead in
georgia joe biden's currently in
georgia's 14
000 votes now whether those votes are
legitimate or not and i think there is a
lot of evidence of irregularities all
over the country
it is simply a fact that it's going to
be very difficult just historically it's
very difficult to overcome those kind of
margins because recounts don't usually
flip them now you also have to remember
we're in an unprecedented territory
because we've never had widespread
unsolicited mail-in votes
so it opens up the system to a lot more
fraud
and theoretically it should make it
easier to flip votes if they're
illegitimate votes
but maybe it won't maybe the court
courts won't catch up so all these
little 800 votes here a thousand votes
here
it's gonna be really important if there
is any hope
to uh to overcome the establishment
and overcome the blob and get us get
ourselves another
trump term uh trump is currently leading
biden in floyd county
by a 43 margin of difference was it just
an accident that those
votes disappeared maybe
yeah maybe it was i wouldn't put money
on it but maybe it was
this is the problem there are a lot
we're hearing about a lot of these
irregularities and time
is running out and the official sources
we are told have already called the
election for biden
this one this one really scandalized me
and i have a low opinion of course of
big tech
and the media but this scandalized me
trump tweets out
i won the election very very simple
and twitter i mean put now they put
little warnings on all of his tweets
and they say quote official sources
called this election differently
that is not true official sources
have not called this election in fact
the only
official sort the most official source
that has called this election
is president trump who is the president
of the united states who said
i won the election may turn out
that he does not get a second term for
whatever reason
but if you want to talk about an
official source trump would be the most
official source the official sources who
call elections are the states who
certify the results
then the official sources are the
electors who vote for the president on
december 14th
those are the official sources
twitter is not an official source the ap
cnn fox news even not official sources
you won't find them in the laws of the
united states certainly not in the
constitution
they're not there but this is a power
grab this has always been a power grab
this is an alternate universe where
the the official sources the real
official sources the president for
instance the states
the electors well they're all
illegitimate how long has the left been
prattling on about getting rid of the
electors all together the electoral
college
in this alternate universe and this
alternate leftist universe
the official sources are the cnn
the official sources of jack dorsey and
twitter the official sources are of
course i can't forget
last but not least dr fauci our true
ruler he's been with us through i think
six presidential administrations
presidents come and go dr fauci stays
and dr fauci is now flexing his power
showing his political arrogance as
hubris
who really rules us in this country the
administrative state
dr fauci uh one among many but but a
prominent one
he came out and just said that president
trump okay enough funny games guys
enough counting the ballots enough
following the legal process in the
constitution
trump has to succeed to secede not
secede concede
maybe he should succeed too that'll be a
topic for another day trump has to
concede
for public health the virus is not going
to stop and call a timeout
while things change the virus is just
going to keep going the process is just
going to keep going
this is something that just is now going
in the very very strong right direction
the vaccines are effective we want to
get it approved as quickly as we
possibly can
we want to get doses to people starting
in december and then we want to really
get the ball rolling as we get into
january february and march
we want to smooth a process for that and
the way you do that
is by essentially having the two groups
speak to each other
and exchange information that's not true
that's just not true that's just a lie
donald trump does not need to talk to
joe biden to get doses of the vaccine
out in december
because contrary to what the media are
telling you or dr fauci wants
president trump is the president in
december and in january for that matter
and he doesn't need joe biden to help
him i know the media have been trying to
frame this
as joe biden's wonderful vaccine this
was all trump they mocked trump they
said there's no way he's going to get a
vaccine by the fall
then he did because he handled this very
well
and then we get the vaccine and now
we're told but
we can't get it out in december unless
he concedes immediately and ignores the
legal process in the constitution
the way fouchy talks he says look i get
it i get it we have this
pesky constitution thing but look the
virus
doesn't care science doesn't care about
your
ridiculous little politics your laws
your rules
science doesn't care so we need to
ignore your politics and your rules and
your constitution
because we need a scientific government
that's exactly what woodrow wilson wrote
about
this is exactly what all the early
progressives wrote about and you hear it
from progressives today
up to and including presidential
candidate joe biden
that's what you hear oh look science
tells us we got to ignore
global warming is going to kill us all
five years ago or whatever it was
supposed to kill us
and so that's why we have to give our
sovereignty away to international bodies
and have them write our laws for us
because you know
because global warming is going to kill
us in the 70s no sorry that was global
cooling in the 70s well someone's going
to kill us
give away your rights give away your
political tradition
i don't think so i don't think we need
to tell joe biden a damn thing to get
that vaccine out in december
and i hope that the president doesn't i
don't like dr fauci i'm finally willing
to say that okay
we've been making jokes about dr fatty
for a long time i don't like him i think
he's incompetent
at just about everything other than
going on television with a
straight face and contradicting what he
just said the day before
what has he gotten right about this most
famous thing he did in this entire
pandemic was to go on tv early on and
say don't get a mask
now we're told you have to wear a mask
all the time even when talking about the
vaccine he said yeah it'll be seventy
percent effective now we're told it's
gonna be 90 95
effective fatigue said that was
basically impossible
why are we listening to him the guy's
been wrong about everything he's just
sort of likable on tv to certain people
who don't know any better
he's a slick politician well fine if
he's he wants to be a politician run for
office buddy
run for office run for congress run for
the senate run for president
he thinks he's the president he thinks
he can tell the duly elected president
what to do
because when it comes to democrat
presidents progressive presidents
often the experts and the bureaucrats
can tell them what to do
but he can't always tell trump what to
do fauci
has a very anti-american view
of the relationship between experts and
the bureaucracy and the administrative
state
and politics and this guy never wants to
give up power
because he knows if biden wins if biden
ascends to the presidency
he's got that perfect kind of
progressive president who's going to let
the experts
run the country joe biden just told us
this the other day
here's what i do let me tell you what
the health experts have said to me
um and it's not because i'm unique and
president-elect it's because my family
they strongly urge that if in fact
we're going to have thanksgiving with
anyone
that we limited to a maximum
maximum they suggest five people maximum
10 people
socially distance worry mass and people
who have quarantined
so jill and i spent this morning
like many of you trying to figure out
what are we going to do for thanksgiving
how are we going to do it and we've
narrowed down which family members and
that they were tested
recently tested in 24 hours and so
i would strongly urge for the sake not
just your sake for the sake of your
children your mother your father your
your sisters your brothers whoever you
get together of thanksgiving
think about this there should be no
group more than 10 people in one room
at one time i mean in in inside the
homes that's what they're telling me
they're telling me they're you know
making sure that that's the case
that's what they're telling me that's
what they're telling me to do
and now i'm telling you to do that
because i'm the duly elected president
that's what joe biden thinks
i don't think he's that yet we'll find
out when they certify the votes but what
he's saying is i'm the duly elected
president
and i'm nothing but a conduit for the
experts and the bureaucrats
who have been wrong about everything to
rule this country that's what he's
saying
that's that's how they do it i mean that
is that is much more the permanent
government
than these elected guys even someone
like trump who's a real innovator is a
guy really shakes things up
they come and go trump is getting it
most two terms
even if it all works out in our favor
he's at most getting two terms
i'm waiting for him to pull at charles
the second you know disband parliament
and uh just rule for like
years and years and years but it's
probably not going to happen so he'll
come and go
and fouchy will remain and the permanent
state will remain and they will
tell us what to do how unmanly
for a president to come up there and say
well the experts told me i can't have
thanksgiving so ah shucks
okay we're not having thanksgiving you
know the experts who were wrong about
everything yeah they
that's what they said so anyway maybe
maybe we'll get a thanksgiving next year
oh my gosh give it a rest
how un-american how pathetic how totally
pathetic what a gosh if this guy
actually wins
this is going to be a very very
humiliating few years who knows how long
it could be could be could be four years
i guess
who knows that is the government that
we've got
the scientific experts you know
scientific experts
who say that men are women scientific
experts who say the babies
aren't human scientific experts who say
that
cloth masks don't do anything but then
they say the cloth masks are super duper
important you gotta wear them all the
time
you know them well they've got a they
were attacking this book
you saw this book that my friend abigail
schreier put out irreversible damage
the transgender craze seducing our
daughters abigail schreier
believes that adults if they want to
mutilate their bodies and you know men
look more like women or women look more
like men it's totally fine she is
basically as liberal as you get on that
question of transgenderism
but what she said very modest suggestion
she said maybe we shouldn't
castrate children you know children are
not at the age of consent
they don't they don't know very much
that's why they're
children right they need to be educated
they need to grow up they need to mature
and
so maybe we don't irreversibly mutilate
their bodies
before you know they're 12. just a
thought
and then this was there were all these
radicals who protested got this taken
off the bookshelves at target
thankfully target put it back on they
were talking about this when i was
filling in for rush on friday
we kind of made a big deal about this it
was just bubbling up then but i think by
the end of the show
by the end of the day that day there was
such a conservative backlash
that target decided to put it back on
that's good but in the academy
they don't want to put that book back on
the shelves in higher education they
want to burn the book
uc berkeley english professor grace
lavery supports
bernie literally burning abigail
schreier's book grey slavery
now great that's kind of interesting i
just agree it sounds like gray slavery
and the name is a made-up name because
grace slavery is not a woman
grace lavery is a man who identifies as
a woman
which actually people reporting on this
story apparently don't know that but
just kind of googled the guy and yeah it
turns out he's a trans woman
so this this uc berkeley professor grace
slavery says
since some people have misunderstood my
tone and censorship
is an important matter and as a public
educator i have a duty to be precise let
me clarify i do not advocate to facing
library books
i do encourage followers to steal
abigail schreier's book
and burn it on a pyre please make sure
you use a safe buyer
and that you have an extinguisher to
hand to be safe when you are burning
books remember all you're doing is
removing a commodity from circulation
much as one might destroy a contaminated
crop or take action if a distributor
failed to do so
now it's easy to attack this lunatic
this person living in an alternate
universe where english professors are
supposed to burn books
but i actually think he's making a point
that is worth conservatives considering
because
conservatives now take up the mantle of
free speech absolutism
we just support all speech at all times
and it doesn't matter how coarse or how
crass or how subversive
or how seditious or how treasonous even
we support all speech
you can never get in trouble for speech
and that's always what conservatives
have supported and the left is
is pro-censorship okay i think we're
overstating our case a little bit i
think that we're ignoring the haze code
the haze code which you know forced a
kind of
standard on popular culture which
conservatives supported and radicals
opposed
and conservatives rightly supported it
and the best movies in american history
were made under the haze code
uncoincidentally i think we're
forgetting the house on american affairs
committee which
rooted out communists from the
government and which did engage in a
sort of censorship and engaged in a sort
of speech code
and a kind of standard i think we're
forgetting that and i think
when we pretend that conservatives or
have no standards at all were falling
into a trap of political correctness
political correctness when it developed
there are a lot of terms for it it came
up in the
really beginning in the 20s and 30s and
it's come up all the way through the
present
political correctness is really devious
and it's really effective because
it's two things at once it's a speech
code
right it's a it's a list of words we
have to say and that we can't say and
behaviors that we have to engage and we
can't behave in
and it's also an anti-speech code
namely it destroys the old standards
whatever political correctness
is a negative vessel it is an attack
on the old standards and
so so to use a simple example now
uh you know in the in the olden days we
used to have sort of moral
program for certain sexual behaviors
because of you know because of
traditional sexual morality christianity
judaism islam even and
today we're told the opposite is true so
if you you know you see the kind of
internet meme of die
cis scum or the idea that
heterosexuality is
is not just on an equal playing field
with homosexuality it's actually worse
because it's oppressive or cisgenderism
namely if you're a man and you know that
you're a man
you're a cisgender is not just on an
equal ground
with transgenderism a man who thinks
he's a woman but it's actually worse
because it's oppressive
men are worse than women because men are
oppressive in the patriarchy
white people are we worship whiteness in
america it's a white supremacist country
it's actually worse than the other races
it's it's a total flipping right this is
not to say
that traditional behaviors uh couldn't
use a little work of course all
behaviors at all times could use work
because it's a fallen world
but to utterly flip
the traditional christian moral standard
for instance or even ancient moral
standards
in favor of radical leftism premised on
uh extraordinary extreme materialism
extreme individualism extreme all these
various things
is is an anti-speech and so if you
the trick of political correctness is if
you go along with political correctness
then the radicals get their way but if
you oppose political correctness on the
grounds that you oppose
all standards and codes and things like
that the radicals also get their way
because what they were trying to do is
attack the old standards so as long as
you say look
i'm against political correctness and
i'm against all speech codes
then you're saying okay they get to have
explicit content all over tv
they get to degrade the culture in
movies they get to have
weird stuff going on all the time that
you they get to push their radical
policies and you really can't say very
much about it
because you've said there are no
standards at all in reality
there is always a sort of censorship in
all cultures and societies
there are certain things that are just
out of bounds that you're just you can't
say and you will be ostracized for it
and you may even have some punishments
for it we've had that in america all the
time we've had laws against obscenity
from the very beginning
and no one ever said the first amendment
protected obscenity
at least at least only fringe people
have said that
we've always had that we've had laws
against sedition we have laws against
threats we have laws against fighting
words
and that doesn't violate the first
amendment there are things that are out
of bounds or things that are out of
bounds for conservatives there are
things that are out of bounds for
leftists and what this
berkeley professor is saying is yeah we
need to move those bounds
sometimes it's called the overton window
or that's another term for it
we need to move these bounds more in
favor of the left so that perfectly
mainstream things like
don't trans the kids are now so
unacceptable
that you will be ostracized you'll be
called a bigot you could lose your job
maybe you could be punished by the
government for it
and i think what conservatives need to
say is not we need to lose all standards
and it's fine if you want to trans the
kids that's you know that's fine if you
want to you do you or whatever
instead of that we need to say okay we
want to have a good standard
we want to have a good standard that
everybody likes that
that allows people to flourish that is
not a that's not oppressive that's not
bigoted that's not any of that
but that preserves culture and allows
human beings
to flourish that that's what we have to
do
that's the the adult version of this
guy's conversation
of what he's trying to push and i think
in a way
this this professor is is pointing out a
mistake
conservatives have made and and if we
want to quit living in alternate
universes
we need to drop this idea that it's just
a the society is a neutral playing
ground and anyone can do whatever they
want that's not true
when you believe that anyone can just do
whatever they want all the time and
there's no consequence to that
which has never been true in any society
then you get this polarization then you
get this balkanization then you get
these alternate universes what we really
need to do is actually engage with the
other people and say no
this is better than that no i think you
should consider this instead of that no
actually
you should wave the flag instead of burn
the flag no i think we should actually
be ruled under the constitution
not under whatever rule dr fauci put out
i think actually the dually elected
president is more official
than some bureaucrat in some random
department somewhere
we need to have a standard and defend
that standard that requires courage that
requires you might say manly courage
and unfortunately as candice shows us
that is in short supply i'm michael
knowles this is michael noll show i'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton